sono venuto non fa vj oggi we are back
to be will do siamo tornati ragazzi su
api wales e tra l'altro l'ultimo
episodio avevo interrotto un momento
bruttissimo della vita è tra l'altro è
riuscito a perdere la maggior parte dei
livelli forse stavolta riesca a fare
meglio botto al flip 6.0 ormai sono
tutti botto il flip se ci riprova un
miliardo di volte non ci riesco rai
alquanto strano sto video game sta
diventando fantastico mica mensa tese
ricadevano tutti in piedi mi sarebbe
stato troppo epico la [ __ ] i miei piedi
subito dopo gli olo bene
goditi la cena bottiglia lasciamo
perdere il flip delle bottiglie che
ormai sta diventando una roba passivo il
probabili probabilmente impossibile
grazie per avermi dato una speranza
azienda speranta come cazzo parlo io
ultimamente il rischio dirle malaka gare
dai zio secondo me sta anche abbastanza
comodo reja plastica chevalley cosa ho
schivato
[Musica]
cosa sta succedendo sono aggrappato
fermi cosa stai facendo zio maghetti
laura usare qualcosa la fusione come
elastico bravissimo bello che non ci
sono neanche attaccato ci credo sono
caduto
e stato bellissimo finché è durato ce
l'ha scritto probabilmente impossibile
qui c'è una speranza
credo
[Musica]
va bene va bene va bene così oltre all
grande famiglia questa la semplice la
stava caricando il mio computer sta
caricando la reaction di incazzatura che
sto per avere halloween prima
maledizione eh va beh
[Musica]
ma che chiede lei if you can
perché oggi tutti quanti mi si sfidano
con le problema ci avete dopo mi chiamò
la cazzo lo prese di schiena
vai frate va infatti dai frate non di
qua perfetto che tuffo fatto bellissimo
[Musica]
crisis world for words folle da una a
questo è uno sport trovo mi hai mentito
ma non vale
non è uno smartphone di smartphone sono
altri quello che ho fatto lo scalpo a
temi che non te ne frega
talmente scazzato che le spade gli
passano attraverso c'è veramente
meraviglioso quelle giornate in cui ti
svegli non ci voglia neanche di morire
fantastico ai vai vai così c'è un
braccio infilzato
grazie per avermi stordito le orecchie
ne avevo proprio bisogno mlg jump ci
manca solo che trovo io topi in mezzo a
sta roba
ok cosa vuol dire meglio gigia siete
stronzi vuol dire questo ma che è pur
incastrato
ma mi fate toccare il traguardo cosa
facciamo così guarda è neanche così un
idiota
ti piace vincere facile ma neanche
quello perché tanto non ci arrivo
e stato un livello difficile kill bill
isf m2 dei bad bad dover mam secret love
her mica che bel segreto perché c'è la
mamma billi il billy tour in kill bill è
morto sono forte veramente si riveli di
api sono di un senso pauroso rock swing
grazie a dio è di no perché mi
chiaramente ovviamente mi stavano
mettendo chi non sa che mi hanno messo a
i rock swing che fa veramente cagare
almeno è di sa come si fanno mica li fa
solo lui non mi dà indicazioni zero sono
capaci i rosa si costituì che non si è
capaci migliaio deficiente aspetta tre
secondi o prendiamo ethel aprendo la
prendo
porca eva cielo quasi peccato aver tanto
vinco uguale chi se ne frega no il casco
madonna come lo schivato bene
meraviglioso non so neanche come ho
fatto a schivarle se cose win
grazie it's my birthday tanti auguri
tanti auguri a tua madre pensa che non
me ne frega un cazzo che il tuo
compleanno e tu hai fatto un livello per
il tuo compleanno quanto nessuno non è
venuta la tua festa di assassination
l'assassinio pesca assassino è verde
cazzo era questa roba replay
c'è però nessuno potrebbe mai sospettare
di me perché come mika fa un assassino a
fare questa cosa che lei kick categoria
che botto malissimo perché stai alzando
la maionese zio che problemi ci hai
l'impossible jump bike
no kenny forse non ho capito il livello
a ok presidente john point che vi devo
cercare quando esplode cazzo ma di
stronzo forte ma che cazzo sei fhiaba
dai fratelli nicchia quanto idiota ma
come fai a mancarlo di così poco c'era
anche incredibile 90
e sarà meglio e grazie che mi avete
messo pure il telo per non farmi male
parco or mica una cosa devi fare il
fiore parkour giusto e scritto
sbagliatissimo va bene avevi solo un
lavoro da fare è l'hai fatto pure de mer
da fermo in attivo
ok che perché parkour è questo ma tu sei
cos'è il parco ok è bene questo non è
parco zio ma va bene mi sto divertendo
lo stesso effetto vai vai non ce l'ho ce
l'ho letto ho fatto due palle non sono
anche dove ma va bene
sono usciti arrivare al traguardo senza
niente triple street
no ti prego questo stavo giusto dicendo
che quelli col vetro non riesco a farli
motivato una testata che minchia zio
spostati city o non sei una ballerina
però ripigliati va il fratello non così
porca eva perché ti devi buttare le
spine in testa
spy forma sono già morto niente che ok
ok perfetto perfetto effetto fa chi è a
saint veit dei disaster porta faq che
disaster oddio ma sta succedendo
cadono cose ma io sono forte e veloce
sta succedendo domanda cosa sto facendo
aiuto
va beh secondo me sono sopravvissuto poi
boxart e intersos miglia è il livello
della vita questo e ho ben due motivi
per dirlo ciao tesoro come stai cosa
faccio c'è un libro ma è unanime non lo
conosco sorry
adesso sì che ciò due bei motivi per
amare sto livello sapeva grazie quanto
gentili oggi quanto bello è felice sta
diventando ultimamente forse adesso è un
po esagerato
non importa no no no non si fanno queste
cose non posso mettere questa roba beh
tanto censura primo qua attacco attacco
della vagina
ah no è semplicemente sere per coprire
denudare letizia non aveva bene va bene
così end grazie è stato proprio bello
questo livello ne facciamo un altro così
kim prossimo al 95 per cento ok capitana
sempre porca [ __ ] o team indovinare
anzi porca [ __ ] ma perché non riesco
più a fare un cazzo è per niente o
ragazzo
assurdo secondo me sono ancora vivo però
giusto dubbio no qualcosa trottola cero
maledizione ora vivo è no no sono vivo
dai ne ha colpito solo il cazzo non me
ne faccio niente ci sono le tipe di
prima non già fatto loro ok ok adesso
non hai colpito allo stesso punto di
prima prova bene che decidi tu quando
morire o no vabbè zio non importa
impossible ii ormai posso tutto io forse
non proprio tutto porca [ __ ]
stimatissime stimatissime sono
fortissimo suo fortissimo ci sono
relazioni
[Musica]
ok skylife proprie che esagerazione rega
che devo fare
dacci mi porti per favore in piazza
duomo grazie perfetto
no non è piazza duomo mi scusi può
rallentare che non c'è neanche alle
cinto discussi miskolc a che mi aiutò
polizia sono stato sequestrato dove va
beh guarda che dopo un po l'atmosfera
finisce non sono la cosa che ti dico io
perché sono studiato di mills
ho centrato il come ma sono vivo ma ha
peccato sono morto no perché la
veramente figo anno perfetto l'effetto
tensione peggiori e ti vai uk
grazie per non avermi deluso neanche
questo è ancora come cazzo è che vive
sempre io muoio che problemi ragazzo
livello potrebbe essere più complicato
del previsto
ok sono ivo fermi sono vivo sommesso
male però solo vivo importante quello
che è perfetto vai vai non sono anche
con quale gambe ma vai
sono ancora vivo ai ragazzi mi muovo c'è
traguardo forse lo raggiungo forse lo
raggio forze meraviglioso e dulcis in
fundo cad oppure sul punto di partenza
c'è tanta roba varia roba cioè meglio di
così nella trappola un livello pieno di
emozioni
tutto nel culo ci hai messo 12 ore per
caricare un livello così abelli che sono
un fenomeno ne son riuscito a finirlo ma
[ __ ] va a vedere che sorride che
posso concludere qui per quest episodio
di api wheldon che andrai a quanto
stanno diventando difficili veli
ultimamente vincere è un macello
prevedere sia piaciuto ragazzi come se
io sono un commento è un mi piace anche
a face di facebook come miglio trattare
descrizione soliti schemi ci vediamo al
prossimo vito era ragazzi